take a long hard look remember it take a  look at this take a good hard look this  is what they did to me I don't remember  my family or my country nothing you have  a British passport and you're my  daughter I don't know my own name  the only thing I know is that it  happened to nearly a million people and  I will never forget it and neither  should anyone else where are you from  originally originally from loving  parents do you see yourself as a patient  or a protagonist I'm a genocide survivor  that's why I tried to kill myself I'm  looking for the truth where you were  born  it's not always easy just to come out  with the truth the International  Criminal Court is now in session some  things are best left forgotten  [Music]  [Applause]  keeps giving me things about my past  why what everyone has been lying to you  the only child cover LLL escape from the  past is for everyone to recognize it the  truth is far more complex that you may  wish to hear  [Music]  you